good morning John so obviously I just
turned 30 and in general I'm realizing
that I'm no longer what you would call a
young person and beside the fact that I
just received the best birthday present
that anyone's ever received from people
from Basra to Ohio there's a tiny bit of
bitterness to this whole being 30 thing
and I kind of wanted to talk about see
what this is making me realize I
wouldn't mind being young forever so you
know immortality I can have it so
there's a bunch of different paths that
you could take to get to immortality and
I'm gonna talk about ten of them right
now
path number one hoping for good medicine
I mean let's be honest there are tons of
people hard-working good people working
their butts off to eliminate the
diseases that kill people so all we got
to do is cure heart disease and cancer
and all that stuff until life expectancy
starts to go up more than one year per
year and then you're good all you got to
do is make it to that point and then
they'll always be fixing whatever is
wrong with you before it actually
happens or at least before it kills you
path number two travel for a long period
of time at near the speed of light now
I'm not gonna pretend that I understand
why this is but apparently if you're
traveling near the speed of light time
passes more slowly for you compared to
the rest of the universe so if I got the
spaceship that goes to the speed of
light I get in it and I go and then I
come back and it takes me like two years
on earth many years will have passed and
then hopefully they will have cured
whatever was wrong with me
path number three cryonics is basically
the same thing as speed of light travel
except that freezing it's a little less
cool honestly bad number four bathed in
the blood of virgins just get it in your
hair there you know it's a it restores
your youth at least that's what
Elizabeth báthory thought so I don't
know whether that works or not I'm not
saying it doesn't work I'm probably
gonna steer clear that one anyway path
number 5 the the singularity futurist
Ray Kurzweil believes that there is a
point at which machines will be able to
build machines that are smarter than
themselves and then from then on they
will just continue building smarter and
smarter machines forever and the
explosion and intelligent machinery will
change everything this includes
theoretically the machines helping us
save ourselves which is funny because
that's not how it happens in science
fiction once the machines get smarter
than us no matter what they they're not
like oh thanks for creating us here's
immortality no generally they see you as
less useful Ben Affleck splotchy
PAP number six being jellyfish there's
one kind of jellyfish it's called the
immortal jellyfish which can shift back
and forth between its polyp stage and
its adult
and it can do this perpetually meaning
basically that it can just live forever
it is literally immortal also probably
not gonna go this route because being a
jellyfish doesn't sound very fun number
seven selective breeding this would take
a very long time also it would take a
very dedicated and evil dictator so some
evil immortality crazed dictator was
like you cannot have sex until you are
50 then all the children born of that
generation will be guaranteed to be
stronger than children born of like 20
year olds because the 20 year olds would
have had to have reached the age of 50
now after thousands of years of doing
this you actually select for people who
live longer and then you start saying
you can't have sex until you're 60 and
then 70 and then 80 and a 90 it would
work but it would be really evil path
number eight telomerase telomeres are
the things that cap our chromosomes
there at the end there and scientists
think that two limbs breaking down is
the reason that we get older all the
stuff are skinny getting saggy our
brains getting stupid our bodies falling
apart all that stuff caused by telomeres
breaking down now there's an enzyme that
actually repairs telomeres and it's
called telomerase and mice that are
genetically engineered to produce more
of this stuff live 50% longer than other
mice why are they putting that in
vitamin water path number eight let
someone turn you into a robot lots of
futurists think that will either be
putting our brains into robot bodies or
will actually be downloading the
thoughts and memories that comprise
ourselves into computers which I'm
pretty sure and pretty happy I'm not
gonna live to see it sound very
interesting but it does not sound like
what I have come to think of as life and
finally number 10 trees here's how
this one works when you turn 30 you have
to have an awesome enough brother to get
a bunch of people to organize and plant
trees and other plants so that when you
die there will be trees that were
planted because of you and you will be
dead but the trees will still be there
being beautiful and living their lives
John and everyone who helped out with my
amazing birthday thank you all so much